Hello everybody, my name is markiplier and we are curren tly in st. Louis for the very first show of the year
Welcome tour. My name is Ethan Nester. I am 21 years old
I'm from Portland Maine and originally and I am part of the cast for the you're welcome tour. Sure. My name is Tyler Scheid
I'm from Cincinnati, Ohio
I'm 28 years old. I'll be 29 and what is today?
I'm Wade Barnes I've known mark for a long time 10 15 20 years. I don't know somewhere in that range
What else did you want to know?
I'm Bob Bob muysken. Muyskerm on youtube,twitch and everything?
I'm from North Carolina right now. I grew up in Ohio though, and I I went to college in Cincinnati
which is actually where I met mark.
*extremely awkward confusion*
That's cool, I'm Dan ring from Los Angeles
Yeah, that's me from the top. Yeah
(Queue epic music)
(Queue music again)
I don't even know how this is gonna be presented. This is gonna be like a DVD
This is gonna be like a Netflix special. It's gonna be a miniseries. Come on. Could it be a multi-part could put on the jam?
Anecdote about st. Louis there is dog poop everywhere. It is the first show of the leg
So the first show was always a little bit. Everybody's always a little bit nervous
There are those butterflies of uncertainty when we haven't run a show in a little while
Today's the third. So in 22 days, it'll be my birthday
when you when you do the same show back to back the way that we've been doing the other tours or the other legs of
This tour it sort of feels like you remember everything because you just did it, you know 24 hours ago
but it's been a couple months now, but it still feels
new which is exciting but also weird because the last time I did this it felt like I could do it half asleep and
I will be 29. So that's a little bit about me
Today instead of rehearsing for most of the afternoon and I spent pretty much the whole afternoon in an urgent care
Waiting to see a doctor seeing a doctor waiting at the pharmacy. So I do have like a little eye infection
it's honestly not that bad, but it's a
You know, you don't want to get worse because we're about to be traveling for two weeks
Mark said be nice
Easy nice that just killed markiplier. I feel like that's a back door for you to
Read sometimes
I'm most excited for
More time to spend with my friends and more time to
rehearse with people and relax with people and see the cities that we're gonna see because
Last time I was working on who killed markiplier on the bus, I was editing while I was on bus
So the majority of the time that I was you know
Prepping before the show was spent on the video and not on actually thinking about the show
So here I have a hundred percent of my time just dedicated absolutely to making sure the show is the best that it can be
Working
So I've actually known Mark since third or fourth grade
He says fourth I argued third for a while, but we'll go at fourth grade. So I've known him a
Huge portion of my life. He just in 2016 invited me to come out and work with him
and so I've been working with them since
September of 2016
When I moved out to LA and so it's been really really eye-opening and really neat getting into the industry and working with them.
I went to the University of Cincinnati for college and that's actually where I met mark
and Wade and Tyler all through Mark I was uh,
The first time I ever talked to him
I called him because they like sent his phone number to me and we're like introduce yourself
This is your randomly assigned roommate and I was like, okay, I'll call this guy. We talked on the phone for like two minutes
I think most of the conversation was hi. I'm Bob
Hi, I'm mark
I have an Xbox but I don't have a TV and he was like well
I have a TV and I only have a Wii so we should be good to go and
that was our first interaction and that
Pretty much defined our first year. He introduced me to world of warcraft
Which he played a ton and I introduced him to being obsessed with Guitar Hero 3 which we played a lot
Yeah, and that was how we got to know each other. We were friends
Pretty much since that first phone call
I think I think we've known each other for the past like two and a half or two years and
He and I have both been doing YouTube for about five years
We met each other at conventions and just through different friends and stuff like that
And then he asked me to come out to LA and I said yes, I would like to come out to LA. So I did
Well, there was the proposal which was amazing, oh
We got a message in our little idea box that people write down on cards and they said that hey I want to propose
Can I do that more like? Oh sure. Yeah
Okay, see this is really important that I did this year
Because
You finally got the courage to actually go out with me because you wanted to be a better person for mark
Was seeing that couple get up on stage in the proposal it was so cute it was so adorable
That was that's always just like really really crazy to see stuff like that happen
To see that what we do means so much to them that they would want to
propose to their significant other
At an event that we're doing
It's it's really really special and it really sort of hones in that feeling of like what we're doing actually means something to people
Alright let's get real we just got through the first night of the show and there's already a lot of controversy in the group
I don't know how long we can last
Marks a little bit tough to work with Bob. I think the pinkeye is spreading to his brain. It's really starting to affect him
Tyler's been coming after me. I think he's getting rabid and I even always seems like he's on the brink of crying
I feel like the group is falling apart, and I don't know what to do
Stay tuned
We'll see what happens
Night two, you know the sophomore night it's a
An easy trap to get into to be overconfident that we actually know what we're doing
So if we constantly remind ourselves that we have no talent and there's no hope of us actually being entertaining
Then we kept our standards really low, and maybe we'll have a good night
Mark's beautiful singing
But probably not make sense
We did a full run-through which we didn't have time before yesterday
So I think after yesterday's show and the rehearsal today were in pretty good shape and we're definitely awakened on our feet.
I am very excited for mark I've been here since like 3 o'clock in the afternoon
freezing because I thought they were gonna let the VIPs and the non VIPs in but then I was like
Well, we got you man. We got you. Yeah, I'm just like yeah North freezing my fingers
What about Ethan wave Bob and Tyler? Oh, yes. I am super stoked to see them neighbor
neighbor
Why is my wife over to your house for coffee? And why is your wife over at my house for coffee a
Lot could ask you the same thing. Well too late
I already did because I'd be funcle' in that you are creating a
Conspiracy to cheat on my wife and you're forcing me to feel bad about it by making me cheat on your wife
All right, you caught me red-handed
All right, you caught me blue handed
I don't think that's true
Well, it don't matter what you think. It's true when your pants are down and you're deep well
I'm gonna put on my x-ray glasses and see into the olden days.
Put the screw in the tuna
I
Understand what's wrong now
That screw came loose from up here, didn't it?
You see Jim you confused me because I know you're not even married
You see Jim i've been your wife the whole time.
I'm gonna change that even though I couldn't hear anything
Cuz I got a screw loose too. Look
Alright, I just got done sleeping with your wife
And if you got done sleeping with mine, maybe we should get revenge on the both of them
First of all, I didn't sleep with your wife. She slept with me
Well, look bygones can be bygones if you let my anger buns
We pack a couple thousand people into a room
and it really puts things into perspective as well because
We all have hundreds of thousands of people
That are subscribed to us in some case millions like Wade has over a million subs and Mark has like 19 million or whatever
But I have like 500,000 people about watching my videos
And so when you get into a room and there's 2,500 people in that room or whatever. It's like wow
This is a lot of people and then you actually think about it and it's like oh well
I have five hundred thousand people that watch my videos and so it really puts things into perspective
As to like how many people are actually watching the videos every day
I'm very lucky to have people in my life that I do between Molly and all these guys than you know
Mandy and Amy and Dana Kathryn
Evans alright guy holding this camera is pretty cool from what I can tell
but our cast our crew I mean
production everyone has been just so amazing and I feel like we've got this big camaraderie this bond that you formed from being on the
Road together that I didn't know existed
so
I'm very thankful. I
Reach the contract
What are you showing off your young agility? Alright, I'm gonna get my cane and stroll back after you
Yeah, well, I hope you do. Yeah, that's right
Bob what do you have to say about this?
He said nice things about you too. It's not a part of this Bob. I mean Wade said nice things about you
All right
This is my interview back over here. You coward I would take everything
I just said bad if it weren't the truth, but unfortunately it is so oh
How dare you!
I hope you say nothing what mean things about me. I will all right time for my interview Wade's a fucking asshole and
He deserves nothing
You're just jealous
Yeah
My ankles divine echo members
What country great modest
Yes
All right. Why do you feel like why do you guys come out on tour?
What's the why for this tour, the why for this tour is?
we
These people that I work with the friends that I have that people that join me on this tour. They're
Important to me because they've been with me since the beginning
So I wanted to do something
with them
that was
Celebrating both the fact that we can work together and have something that's our own and also bring something to our audience
That is completely different than what they've seen out of youtubers going on tour. I
Set it up from the get-go that I wanted to accomplish
A show that I could be very proud of one that I could work with my friends and then also one that would blow people
Away, once they saw it
But when it comes to me and my desire to make something and my desire to exceed my own
Expectations alongside with everybody's expectations when they see something I do
I have to try to go above and beyond what people think I can do and if I can do that with my friends then
That's even better
And
Real talk the pinkeye is spreading
We had a cast member a bob who started whose patient zero and now
Kirsten has it
and I'm a little bit worried because she handles all of our costumes and props so odds are we're all gonna be infected soon and
I've seen a change in their demeanor as it's kind of spread throughout I think morale is starting to really drop
But what keeps it show good. We'll have a good time
as long as we can survive I
I don't know if we can
Um
Denver's nice. I walked around the city. So a little warmer that I thought it'd be
We were supposed to do sing-alongs and then all these lazy bastards decided that they weren't going to work
I've been up since like 8 this morning
Signing badges practicing what I was supposed to be doing and then they all we're all like no
We're not gonna actually do any prep work because we're show or show is earlier today
So we got to get out there and we gotta start warming up or a show is gonna be garbage
So all these lazy assholes need to get the lead out of there
Whatever they keep their lead in and they need to get
Practice
Wade
You need to practice
What are you doing looking at coats?
The venue is warmer inside. The outside was a little bit warmer. I'm excited about the mile high altitude
So you thought affects us on stage if we all pass out?
Well, I mean that's even worse then are you brushing up on your improv skills? Yeah
So but on the pinkeye at all, I know Kirsten got it
Hopefully no one else does but honestly it wasn't that bad for me as soon as I got the medicine like the same night
I put the medicine on it immediately started to feel better. I feel really bad that I gave it to Kirsten
Hope Mark gets it. I don't get it. No deserve pinkeye. Why would you want that? I
Don't want that
Well, you just said that and I hope that I don't or I think you need to get your list of needs and wants in
order because
There's like a need for food
No need for I can I have hopes. Well, yeah, that's hope I hope that yeah, okay
I'm okay with you hoping that and I need them
No, see that's where we fundamentally disagree because needed hope or two different things
You don't if you you always die. If you don't give up if the disease spreading is continuing
Once the camera turns out everyone turns into monsters. I was trying to have a discussion with my friend about rubbing my eyes
Well, no, and then you said you hope you I get your pink eye
I was just standing here doing nothing and then you wanted me to get a disease. I was standing right behind
I'm also doing them. You're not part of this you're
Touching my eye close up and I said nothing you were trying to steal the show man
I wasn't even on camera see Andrew had to move just to get me on camera
Around your big ass eater, so
That's
Okay, not this time I thought it was bare ass farting on pillow Frank's or if your dog has a skin infection
Apparently you can get me a from that until you hate your dog's ass
No
I touched my dog's infected skin and then probably touched my eye at some point without thoroughly washing my hands
Because I had to apply this like spray to her little
Foot that was infected at like three times a day and give her medicine and stuff. That's a too detailed explanation
I usually believe the Sun Bowl answer
Then you ate your dog's ass. That's probably it. Okay. All right. Let's go to your house
They allowed me to be bad when I was bad
Which allowed me to build the confidence that I needed to be somewhat good, and I'm not even saying that I'm good now
But the incremental progress that I've been able to make from the last set to this set has been you know
amazing even for me to say people don't really
See the progress you make day-by-day, but if you just keep at it, you know
Eventually, you'll get to these landmarks where October
I was not good, but I did it and now I'm doing it and it's a little bit better
So next time it'll be even better and then a year from now. It'll be a little better
But it'll only get better if I keep practicing every single day
He was like 4,000
I mean, there's still look for people up there, but still cigarette you really September
Come see man turn water - I mean my friends be drunk
This is it the big one the Mamba Jamba the Big Kahuna the big tuna
This is the one that matters most
God this is the white whale this is the one we got a land
Because this one's being recorded for the special. Anyway, this is uh,
this apparently matters more than anything, but the way we're all preparing is by completely skipping over any possible rehearsal and
Half of us has gone to the strip because we're in Las Vegas
So they're going gambling and I'm sitting around drinking my tea getting ready Oh
A lot of pressure on this one, huh?
You really gonna stick that in my face right now
Look, here's what happened. We rolled in Vegas five in the morning hopped off the bus ready to go. I've been on the casino for
dropping hundies for like
Six seven, I don't know since we got here. I've got like six Jager bombs, so I'm hopped up but I'm chilling out
We haven't burned the place down yet. Maybe we changed our minds. I don't know. We're still gonna take it by storm
We're still gonna knock it over. We're still gonna crush everything in our way. We're gonna go out there on stage. We're just gonna destroy
Everyone's faces so hard that
They wish they were never even brought in this world. I am ready. I'm ready. I'm shaking. I'm
jittery, I'm just gonna scream I forget how the show goes but it doesn't even matter because we
Were here and we're gonna do this, okay?
Am I done?
Can I am I done? Can I go do it?
I'm just I'm just gonna go do the show
writing it
I'm just gonna go do the show right now and oh, I'm so excited
We're gonna be filmed tonight by an actual whole crew and not just
Andrew here who's behind this single camera who's been following us around and forcing us with handcuffs and and
That sounded dirtier than I wanted to I knew I knew we're gonna be filming this but the amount of people that are here
to do the actual like multi camera production
stuff is like way more than I'm used to there's giant cameras with like
$70,000 lenses on them like equipment that
As a youtuber I would never even dream to touch because I wouldn't even know what to do with it
so it is kind of
It's a little bit more hectic. But otherwise just another show
I mean, we're all just sort of hanging out and doing our usual pre-show stuff at this point on your plane
You guys you guys
Green Vegas différents to perform well in Vegas you don't need much more than that, right that's motivation on its own
Well today
In the blue shirt going like this in that back row right there
You jumping up and down in the white shirt right there
So, what's your name?
Mariah nice to meet you everybody give it up for Mariah. Alexis everybody. Give it up for Alexis go full of it
What's your name?
Adam alright on the better teams we have we have Tessa
We have Billy
And Hannah
The better team, okay
Oh
Well, we're gonna need for music dance so that I can kick his ass and get him off my lawn
Go for it
All right, and now Lex what you got
All right
Bringing it back go. Let's go. I like it. I like it
Okay
so to review a little bit of this a little bit of
Something like this
Right and then a little bit of a little bit of this Soulja Boy cranked down a little bit
All right. I think I can do that better dancers. Let's see what you got
Can't wait
I believe in your paid dancers, I'm gonna be your official Old West danced to the death a referee
welcome everybody to tonight's dance to the death will know this works three rounds if nobody dies and
Whoever has red or green, you know, whatever you just vote for who you want to win red dancer
You know the rules you are you ready for round one Bravo boy three, I need a guess sir
Yeah
Yes with a hard-ass. Yes. Sure. Thank you very much. Green dancing to the rules. Oh, you bet. I do gorgeous. Oh
Oh you bet I am sweet sweet sweet
No wrong. I'm gonna accept that as an answer will of dance please spin yourself
All right sweet, it's your first go has one is going to be
a
Good Gimli. Hey check. Alright, this has to be the most cordial dance to the death. I have ever refereed
You know, you're supposed to kill each other, right? Well, you know, I'm a gentleman right gorgeous. I would never hurt a fly. Oh
I'm not Scott sugar tits
Sir it's rude. That is your first wave what that got me my first flash fly
We never disrespect you like that. I know it. All right
Nobody died audience. If you would please pick the winner for round one
Are you ready for round two my sweetheart, you know, I am beautiful. Oh
Real words this time all right, oh
We love dance. Please spin yourself. I've immediately forgotten my second days before
route 2 is going to be
Okay, good answer what do you think about that
Good answer I appreciate you standing up for me, but I could take care of myself. I don't doubt it
I don't - since he smacked you in the face
I'll forgo to your third wave sir
Again, I feel like I have to reiterate you're supposed to be killing each other since that didn't happen audience if you would please
Who won round two!
And another not even close vote run to those two green answer
You guys on this flip sides back and forth willy-nilly like red that's already occurred to this give me a clean and simple
Yes, are you ready for round three?
You have great lips
Actually, I am very proud of my lips I placed a back step that is matching three nature. Are you ready for round three
Yes, I am
Lovely, we love dance if you could spin yourself once more, please
We'll dance three
I feel like you're doing the opposite of killing each other here
Could you please pick a winner for us?
But it looks like round three goes to red dancer!
You know the rules of the waves huh, you know
I declare a
DC regulation 3:10 for five senses number four and I'll ask you right in
for sudden death
Ladies gentlemen ever before my life have I officiated a mandatory sudden-death final round?
This is a very exciting stuff sir before we can begin. I need your confirmatory
butt waggle
Sudden death is initiated bitches. If you could assume the starting position sudden death will begin
Your hair would look great on my wall.
I hope you die
We get sudden death
Ah
Goodness, I always some powerful dance and not a lot of killing. I guess we need the audience to vote one more time guys
Who's it gonna be?
I love the way you smell
Guys
Las Vegas
City that's the one
Big Apple city of brotherly love
the city of sin Windy City, the city of angels
The City... Book of Mormon Queen City city of love city never sleeps the Vagos
Call it where you go where you want to spend your money.
I? guess I'm supposed to talk now
I thought it was pretty cool. I was first time ever nervous the entire time
Normally, it's gone. The instant they cheer during the video, but I was nervous the entire time and puked afterwards, which was awesome
I've never had a nervous puke. So that was interesting a
Rock star but the end of the day everybody said it sounded great. We got compliments from
Someone that's very professional Emily Jillette. Yeah, very nice
absolutely, incredibly nice and
It was... it was weird looking out in the crowd
seeing that arm move in the darkness and just going
Wow, it's looking at me
Real talk real talk time.
I don't think I even have real talk anymore.
there's so much video evidence that everyone's losing their fucking mind and
Tomorrow as good as we feel right now tomorrow we perform in front of the teacher
I don't want to be disappointed in us. I'm sure we'll do great. I'm sure we'll be fine
Good lord, but we haven't we haven't seen her in a bit and I'm worried
Because we've forgotten improv rules and something like that. I don't know. I think it's gonna be fine. I think it's gonna go great
Hopefully we'll make her laugh.
Oh hi guys well
I've been doing improv for Oh God like since like 99.
I started in Minnesota
At the brave new workshop and then I went to Boston and I worked it in for asylum and then I went to New York
And I worked at the pit
Then I went to London and worked at a place called the nursery and now I'm here in LA
That's how I got hired. Just simply he took a he just happened to wander into a class that I was teaching and then
You know hired me from there. I didn't go to the trials
I didn't get to see a lot of the dress rehearsal and stuff because mark is cheap and wouldn't fly me out or
Invite me even mark, you know what you did, you know all the guys were very serious about it. Like they took it seriously
They left egos at the door. They wanted to learn they wanted to get better and they wanted to
Have fun and and they worked so well together that the intensive
that was just more about fine-tuning and
They were very all of them really wanted the most honest feedback
and even when I like they know who was close kind of funny like they never seem to believe me when I said
That was really good. They were like, oh, no I can that can have been good
Like we can handle it Rachel be honest too. Like tell us that we were shitty and I was like I
Don't want to play these mind games with you. You were very good
like I'm not gonna tell you your shit because it wasn't shitty and
And the fact that they just really wanted to learn and took everything so seriously and yet at the same time
you know, we're having fun with it was
It was really great to see because when you're a teacher and particularly with improv people don't want to be there
It really shows it shows
So last night we film the special in Las Vegas it was a
Good show I wouldn't call it the greatest show that we've done. I'm not
Happy with how I did
I never show that I never tell anybody that I kicked myself in the head because sometimes I'm like, oh
Man, I could have done XYZ you always think that after every show you're like I could it on XYZ
I could have done this would have been 10 times funnier than that
You can't deny that you have nerves. You can't deny that you feel anxious. You can't deny that you feel
the
Choking grip of anxiety getting you down before every show and especially in an art form that's dependent on you being happy
You can't deny that
exists, but you can fight it completely you have to
Because when I go out there, it doesn't matter what happens like I am putting everything that I have on the line
Whatever my brain comes up with that's what's happening in and if it's not my favorite thing then that's just too bad
You know, that's the nature of the art form
So do you want to talk a little bit explain to us? Just kind of how this concept came about?
hmm how the concept came about
the concept for this show really came out of
nowhere
Kind of midair the conversation started. We sat down and met with mark was introduced to mark
All Mark knew was like he's like, I really want to give something to the fans
He felt like it was a gift for his fans
wanted it to be something very
obviously true to him to his brand but was open to
suggestions and we just started throwing some things at the board and
See what stuck so really the inspiration for it was
Giving giving back to the fans the challenge is
I Want to prove myself to?
Myself I want to be able to
exceed what I've done before I always want to push myself to go farther in life because I
Constantly need this
Feedback loop of knowing that I'm making progress
I want to show people that you don't have to settle for the very minimum
You can take the hard road and have better chances at success. But for me personally, I always need to know
That I'm moving forward in my life
because I
Hate the feeling of moving backwards. I
Can't stay in one place for too long. I can't let myself become complacent about something. I always have to change things
I always have to
move on from things in and it causes me to let go of a lot of things that are important to me and
It causes me to let go of a lot of relationships that I've had. It causes me to leave behind things that are sometimes
Incredibly important to me, you know, it's it's that obsessive nature that pushes me to do great things
but it's also that obsessive nature that leaves me very lonely at the end of the day and
Honestly, I'm okay with that like this is something that I've discovered about myself only in the past year and I am 100%
Okay with that
Tonight in the Dolby
We had what you might call
Everything that could go wrong did go wrong
So in the opening when we're doing the intro and there's all the music and stuff
There was no sound at all
The mics were working thankfully so mark still did his whole intro and we just played along with it
And then at the end we're like, ah
There's supposed to be sound there. That was weird
We redid the very beginning of the show with no props or anything. We did a double speed it worked out well
But holy shit, it was so scary. That's how good of an improv teacher I am that that even when their keyboardist
Couldn't wasn't working. Right then the the sound was all off. They still kept their shit together
So yeah, and I didn't know that until after the back. I mean, that's how good it was. Oh
Oh I know I know.
(caption writer: i can't translate something about uranus)
About something bigger than this stage or this show tonight, and it's it's planet related
I want to talk about the state of Uranus the planet
Pluto we just kicked it out. It's no longer
The solar system, but why we should respect Uranus
Yeah, how's the energy the mood all that
There's a point in the tour where one sort of hits a big
Dip in energy. I think we'll get the adrenaline for the show tonight, but we're definitely at the point in this leg where
It's starting to be
Probably mostly mentally exhausting to you know, wake up do it again. Keep the same energy. Keep the same focus
It's still fun to do the show, which I'm surprised by
I honestly thought the show would get kind of stale and it hasn't but it's hard to just keep
Bringing it all the way back up and trying to match the energy or even you know top the energy from last night with tonight
because that's
That's kind of what you got to do to keep the show interesting
even if you're tired and sore if you match the energy and you can stay focused, it'll be alright, but
It's getting hard. It's getting harder
One of these huh, that's right build technician stand off
There's people behind me
All right, we'll do this up close and personal like hope your zoom outs as good as your zoom in mr. Big lens
That's right. I'm gonna back up and hope there's nobody there now. Hope your zoom ins is good news about mr. Big grins.
I Got nothing else to say.
Today's like the wednesday of shows
It's like you
You've done your back to the workweek kind of stuff and it's really middle of the week
And I want to say that it's gonna be a good show
I really do like and I think it will be but
Honestly, the energy level across the board even amongst the guys is just pretty low
But at that low energy level we're all feeling really good
Like we hit the comfort zone like it's just like, okay
I just got to keep plugging same level and then when the show starts will obviously kick it up a whole bunch
But for now, it's just like yeah, whatever happens happens
We've got a show to put on and we've got Vlasak to do if you don't do it right now
I'm going to kill you. I'm literally going to be with you
It were the first thing that therapists pull this wasn't we went in yeah, I got it right here
Whoa, go ahead. Let me did we do myself into your heart?
Okay, all right, okay, this is exactly what I was talking about I can't touch her calf, why do you send that to you?
That would be great. Yeah, I'm sorry later. I'll still let you go
Let's get back to the point you heard what our therapist told us. She said the loading is from the Almighty God
You see! you see!
That's what you call it it doesn't mean that you know how to use it
I've always just wanted a little Bologna
So the fans are really what makes the show
Good
Having the head laughter having the cheering. It's such a boost to confidence
like I think almost all of us are energized by the crowds because trying to do
improv and everything else that we're doing in front of no one is so much harder than
having people that support us and care about us and you know have our back so
The show wouldn't be the same if this is just like a recorded show or something
would not be we need the live audience this show requires the fans they are an integral part and I think the fact that we
Have so many different fan interactions during the show
It just makes the case for it as well
we brings fans onstage as much as we possibly can and we can exclude the whole crowd as much as we can and
Even if we didn't like we need you guys
I'll say it we need you guys
Oh
Mark, you know one of my baby's mottos is someone's own got a worse idea
No matter what. I think your firm believer that as well based off charities and understanding you you get what people go through
Can you touch a little bit on?
What you went through? I know you mentioned the tumor and just your personal health things and how they shaped you and change your outlook
Yeah back
Back before I started YouTube. I was in a bit of a low place. I had gotten laid off from my job
I was in a terrible relationship and I was diagnosed with first a
My appendix was about to explode I think is a technical term for it
But while they did a c.a.t scan of my abdomen they discovered that I had a tumor in my left adrenal gland
so I was in a bit of a low place and I
Looked at my life and I was like, you know, this isn't worth giving up over
You know
I still got a lot of potential and I'm just I'm just angry
And I remember that I was laying in bed and I was just thinking to myself like now
How did I let my life get to this point and you know?
There were so many things that were out of my control
But also I needed to feel some semblance like I had control over my life and it didn't really matter to me that
You know, I was suffering like I didn't care that I was suffering. I cared that I allowed my life to
Flow by without me influencing it in any way. I was just kind of drifting through whatever I was doing and
That's just not how I wanted to live my life. So from that day on I decided to commit my life to
Doing things that I wanted to do in the ways that I wanted to do them
I kind of just accept that as a simple truth every day has to be spent on bettering myself in some way and
Every day is spent on self reflecting to see how far I've come.
And you combine the two and you start to make progress in life?
(weird noise)
The look of markiplier
What a show it's been
But it's not over yet
We've got another game for you here and it's gonna be a good one. It's called change
Let's see the game of change based on it
Hey
Kid. Yeah, you want to come in the sewer? No
Like not at all. You sure you don't want to come in the sewer
Hard pass hard pass on that one. I've got Bop it's down here
Did you say Bop it's indeed - did you say you got
Firecrackers down there. Did you say you got an entire collection of a
flubber on DVD down there
That's my favorite movie that much more Wow. What's it do tell what the much more part of that is?
well
Anything your little heart desires obviously my heart desires so much, please explain we've got our
Puppies we've got people who love you
I've got cool makeup on may you can always trust a grown man with clown makeup
You can always trust a grown man. That's carrying around thousands of balloons filled with blood
You can always trust a man that has thousands of copies of flubber on DVDs
Listen kid, I'm gonna come out of the sewer because I'm not one that likes to squat
Whoa
Hey, I thought you'd be taller
That's it okay
Five years ago
One of the my introductions to March Channel was he did a 24 hour livestream and I think he's trying to raise
$1,000 and it came down to like the final hour the final 30 minutes and there was just this big push
Where everyone was like no, this is our goal
We're gonna reach it and at the 24 hour mark
he hit his goal that thousand dollars raised and he was exhausted and tired and we were all like
You know all of us watching we were sitting there for hours and hours watching
And we were just like celebrating by ourselves and our basements like throwing our fists in the other. Yeah, we did it. Yes
the the the foundational idea of the charity stream is really like
just asking and hoping that people will respond and I mean the early streams was literally like let's go to Mark's mom's house and
bring all our computer stuff and just set up and play games and
Every so often we just asked like hey
Check out this link. If you can would you donate and we're all very fortunate to have an audience. That is
Not only there, but also is willing to give back as well this past year in 2016
We did one every single month and it was so cool getting the community together
for a really good cause and we were able to raise so much money over the course of the year for various different charities the
Contribution that fans have done. I mean at this point we had to have raised millions of dollars for charities
It's all about giving back and giving to those that are less fortunate to you
And it doesn't have to be necessarily monetary and it doesn't have to be
Something where you're just throwing money at it and being able to come together and put together something
Bigger than all of us and do something bigger than any single person to help so many people in need
Is absolutely amazing. I can't give myself credit Mark doesn't give himself credit. None of us take any of the credit
We've all donated bits and pieces of it
But the general bulk of all the funds raised for charity has been the fans the audience
So I think the crazy thing is not anything that that I've done or Mark's done or that the team is done
Putting on the stream. I think it's just crazy how much people have responded to that. as I looked at the future
I want to find better ways to get people to
actively engaged with their communities that actively play a part in the role of
Like everything around them
It's so much more than just doing a live stream where we play a game for 24 hours
It is at its core telling people that they have the power to help.
It is
Thursday, October
30th. No, that's a lie, August its August 30th. I don't know what
this tour
This tour was really
Important for me to learn stuff about myself. Number one, It was outside of all of our comfort zones
It was something that we've never really done before it was something that we didn't even know how
It was gonna turn out when it turned out
We came down to this situation where we all pushed ourselves and we all pushed each other and
In doing so we kind of learned who we were
and and not any more than normal life does like
you live on your failures and I can't say that this tour was in any way of failure, but for me it was
It was just this opportunity to grow oddly enough the moments that I don't forget on the stage are not
During the improv games. They're not during the the comedy. They're not during the laughs that we're having
It's during the moments when you know
Were honest to each other the audience is honest us
Those Q&A sessions where people can actually open up their hearts and they can say whatever they want
And and it's what they really really want to say those moments of connection
You can't pay for you. Can't buy that you can't plan for it
You can't program it in those moments when my friends would speak
from their heart about me when I could speak from my heart of all my friends to show people just
How much this meant to us those moments when we can be honest to ourselves and to each other
those are I know for example like
When I always I always call back this but when Bob said on stage, you know, that
We were only there for one reason
you know at its true core at its heart like we were there for one reason and it was because
I had started a YouTube channel, you know, obviously a group effort like I can't take credit for
Like all of this. I wouldn't be here without all the people that were a part of it
Bob said in that moment, you know, it was just
Like it was an honest. Thank you to me and that moment, you know that that little bit of
Seeing what he thought of me
You know seeing how I was in his eyes and seeing like the kind of person he saw me as it was, you know
like those moments are
You can't buy those moments
I think my favorite moment of the tour so far has been actually our last show
where we had an audience participant come up and then completely just
Not do anything
That he was like supposed to do and so like really watching the guys have to like improv their way out of the situation
was really really funny and I appreciate those moments when we first walked into the place back in June and
Tulsa Oklahoma, we had no idea what we were doing
I don't think there was one person on the staff that actually knew what we were doing when we walked in
But we pulled it together and every leg even October to this January run
We have been getting better and better and this show is truly an amazing show and one to see it was absolutely wonderful
Like all around both shows and the second show. We absolutely killed it
And I'm so thankful to be a part of this
I feel like this tour by far has been our most consistent as far as having just
Really really good vibes after each show and having specific memories of each show that are kind of unique most memorable part of the tour
Was in Vegas, I want gambled for the first time and I won $300 just playin ripsaw
I played ripsaw put everything on zero and I crushed it. It's nice to have time because it feels like
Tomorrow like when we do a little party after the last show everything
It feels like you're your whole family that just like everyone flies off in their separate directions
And I don't get to see them again until the next tour really so I'm I'm not sick of anything about the tour yet
See if that changes so we got a lot coming up
but for now
I'm excited to do it again tomorrow and then do it again in February and then do it again later in the year, hopefully so
Okay, so now that it's just you and me because it was terrible like it was so men so much ego just a bunch of
Divas in the room all the time. We rehearsed each of them separately. Everything was scripted
even the really bad improv stuff was scripted because I had to make them look human somehow and it was not
It was not easy and not really easy at all
And I mean I hate I hate to say this but mark wasn't even really at most of the shows
I don't know who that guy was, but it wasn't him. I went in I got my money and I left
And that and that's it. Wait. Did I get all of my money? I
Don't think I got all of my money....
Mark you owe me money
son of a bitch